so kann man das schlaglicht erster
behinderter menschen wir dachten vorher
mit unserem kampf für inklusion wir
wären schon ganz schön weit gekommen und
wir haben plötzlich gemerkt menschen mit
behinderungen werden nicht mitgedacht
sie sind einfach irgendwie am rand und
aus dem blickfeld
dann wären das sächsische lehrer aber
frag ich mich entschuldigung habt ihr
sie noch alle
ich bin der hochrisikogruppe und nur
weil ich zu hause lebt ja trotzdem
behindert menschen mit behinderungen die
zur risikogruppe gehören fühlen sich in
dieser pandemie vergessen
na klar für uns alle war das vergangene
jahr eine herausforderung aber menschen
in der risikogruppe hat es besonders
hart getroffen die mussten sich
teilweise isolieren weil eine kur wird
erkrankung für sie lebensgefährlich wäre
ich habe mich gefragt wie geht es den
betroffenen und was unternimmt die
politik um sie zu schützen
am anfang meiner recherche wird mir
schnell klar ich muss mit raul
krauthausen sprechen
er setzt sich als aktivist für die
belange von menschen mit behinderung ein
und ist selbst seit einem jahr isoliert
zu hause wie sehr alten pro tag 32 e
mails und nachrichten von betroffenen
die einfach auch dann teilweise nicht
mehr durchblicken über die aktuelle
situation die nerven liegen quasi blank
es wenig geht nicht nur um die eigene
eigentlich selber zu erkranken sondern
man macht sich auch keine sorgen darum
was passiert eigentlich wenn die
menschen die für einen da sind die sich
um einen sorgen die einen assistieren
selber erkranken was passiert eigentlich
wenn morgen die ganze logistik
zusammenbricht
die die menschen mit behinderung für
sich selber aufgebaut haben um auch nur
morgens aus dem bett zu kommen da kommt
denn dann und kommt überhaupt noch
jemand wenn bekannt wird dass ich
erkrankt bin
also all solche fragen sind und große
fragen für die jemand wirklich eine
antwort im moment hat alleine die
eigentlich macht schon krank ich habe
von dir gelesen dass du sagst dass
menschen mit behinderung in der pandemie
immer wieder vergessen wurden wo
passiert das denn gerade konkret jetzt
aktuell mit den impfungen sind immer nur
menschen gemein gehen einrichtungen als
in heimen leben aber ein großteil der
menschen mit behinderung lebt in den
eigenen vier wänden ganz so wie es die
inklusion auch will
und die finden in dieser ganzen
aufzählung gar nicht statt was raul
krauthausen meint in der korona im
verordnung des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums werden
menschen mit behinderung die in
einrichtungen leben explizit erwähnt die
die zu hause leben werden erst seit dem
8 februar indirekt in der zweiten gruppe
eingebunden
da heißt es anspruch auf eine impfung
haben personen bei denen nach
individueller ärztlicher beurteilung
aufgrund besonderer umstände im
einzelfall ein sehr hohes oder hohes
risiko für einen schweren oder tödlichen
krankheitsverlauf nach einer infektion
mit dem corona virus saß kopf 2 besteht
das stand in der ersten verordnung vom
dezember hat gar nicht drin
das
jung hat das dann angepasst und sich an
der empfehlung der ständigen
impfkommission der stiko orientiert
darin heißt es es könnten nicht alle
krankheitsbilder oder indikationen
explizit genannt werden es obliegt daher
den für die priorisierung in den
bundesländern verantwortlichen in
einzelfällen personen die nicht
ausdrücklich im stufenplan genannt sind
angemessen zu priorisieren
dies betrifft zb personen mit seltenen
schweren vorerkrankungen oder auch
schweren behinderungen
das heißt betroffene müssen sich selbst
darum kümmern und 111 antrag stellen ich
habe mal geschaut und das ist von
bundesland zu bundesland total
verschiedenen bei manchen gibt schon ein
extra formular bei anderen sind die
infos total versteckt also so richtig
einfach und zugänglich ist das leider
nicht
und menschen mit behinderung machen sich
da auch sorgen nicht rechtzeitig dran zu
kommen
auch auf politischer ebene ich verstehe
aber auch die menschen mit
beeinträchtigungen die in der jetzigen
situation vor dem hintergrund auch der
priorisierung beim impfen sagen das geht
uns einfach nicht schnell genug und bei
allem respekt auch für jetzt politische
entscheidungen bestimmte berufsgruppen
vorzuziehen bin ich schon der meinung
dass das nicht sein kann dass eben
menschen die ein ganz hohes risiko haben
an schweren verlauf zu haben oder gar
tödlichen verlauf zu haben dass die
hintangestellt werden gerade jetzt auch
wo im kapazitäten frei werden also wo
manche menschen tatsächlich imf angebote
nicht wahrnehmen und und deswegen bin
ich schon der meinung da braucht es nach
steuern
seit dem 24 februar wurden in die zweite
gruppe auch lehrer in und erzieherin
aufgenommen wer schon von anfang an ganz
explizit in dieser gruppe genannt wurde
sind menschen mit geistiger behinderung
ganz konkret auf die krankheits trisomie
ein ganz schwieriges beispiel ist zb das
leben zwei schwestern zusammen die eine
hat ein down-syndrom beide sind über 60
jahre alt die frau mit down syndrom hat
auch noch eine schwere lungenerkrankung
jetzt sind in diesem ort impfungen
möglich
die schwester hat im impfzentrum
angerufen und hat festgestellt dass sie
für ihre schwester noch keinen
impftermin bekommt für eine erzieherin
für eine lehrerin hätte sie aber ein
bekommen und das ist für diese frau sehr
sehr bitter gewesen also innerhalb der
zweiten gruppe gibt es dann nochmal
abstufungen und das ist dann wohl der
messe sache wie war denn im vergangenen
jahr die situation in den einrichtungen
der lebenshilfe in denen ja menschen mit
geistiger behinderung leben das
hauptproblem ist ja dann das soviel
weggefallen ist sie waren isoliert in
den wohnstätten sie durften ihre
familien nicht treffen sie konnten nicht
zu ihren tages beschäftigung gehen sie
habe nur gemerkt alles ist ganz anders
sie konnten es nicht einordnen
das heißt sie waren häufig zusätzlich
ängstlich oder waren wirklich in einer
ganz schwierigen verfassung
weil sie das alles so gestresst hat also
gestresst hat die angst was ist hier
passiert hier die sehnsucht die familie
zu sehen in dieser schwierigen zeit
jetzt die familie nicht sehen zu können
und tagein tagaus quasi zu hause
eingesperrt zu sein und das war für die
menschen mit behinderung ganz schlimm
ich würde gerne direkt mit menschen
sprechen wie so oder so ähnlich das
vergangene jahr erlebt haben um stoß in
meiner recherche auf annika die das
undine syndrom hat eine seltene
krankheit bei der die atmung gestört ist
annika ist einverstanden dass ich sie
treffe um das risiko der ansteckung zu
reduzieren habe ich vorher noch einen
schnelltest gemacht
das ist mein bereich der intensivstation
hier wohl genau und also einmal
beatmungsgerät ich bin auf das sieht
dann so aus ich habe ein gendefekt der
das gefühl hat dass ich eben nachts
nicht alleine atmen können also dass
mein gehirn bis zwölf fällt diese nacht
plötzlich sendet sie muss ich eben
sobald ich einen schlag beatmet werden
genau dafür brauche ich diese
waschmaschine
sobald du schläfst du nicht ich habe die
fünf minuten den üblichen bis halt oder
was auch immer das ist aber es hat nicht
lange bist gerade der sauerstoff aus dem
körper raus ist und dann wird es
kritisch
und wie machst du das ja denn mal im zug
so ein mixed dann wäre es nach fünf
minuten kritisch ja also geht er nicht
und dann weiß ich schon ab einem
bestimmten punkt okay als kritisch jetzt
musst du wirklich aufpassen und dann
esse ich wirklich bewusst was trinken
bewusst was die traubenzucker was auch
immer das einfach mein körper einfach
vom 11
er will einfach hoch bleibt und versuche
mich daneben ja zu schützen vor mir
selbst im prinzip seit der korona
pandemie macht sich annika natürlich
noch mehr gedanken wie sie sich schützen
kann
was würde passieren wenn du an corona
erkrankt dass man gute frage ich wenn
ich aus man ehrlich gesagt kein problem
aber ich hatte probleme
ich hatte mal lungenprobleme durch noro
virus und da ist nicht gut geändert aber
ich damit schrauber krankenhaus und das
war fast vorbei also ich es mir nicht
ausmalen
ich würde euch hochrisikogruppe und ich
sollte kein besten davor schützen das
ist nicht passiert ehrlich gesagt wird
ihr das ständig im kopf herum macht für
die sorgen ich versuche das zu
verdrängen und versuche mich nicht immer
damit zu beschäftigen aber natürlich
gibt es momente an denen mir das im kopf
herumschwirrt permanent wäre glaube ich
lüge aber es gibt schon momente wenn ich
zurückfalle oder wenn ich dann im bus
sitzen mir echt immer zusammenlegung
hielt auf dem platz gehabt jedoch lieber
woanders hingeht so wie jeder andere
auch würde ich sagen aber mir nochmal
bisschen intensiver kann mir vorstellen
wir leben ja jetzt seit einem jahr in
dieser pandemie was hat sich denn für
dich verändert dadurch auf jeden fall
massive kontakt reduktion das heißt halt
ganz viel zoomen ganz viel telefonieren
aber ich habe zum beispiel jetzt vor dir
außer meine krankenschwestern seit acht
wochen kein menschen gesehen
sie gefährden damit psychisch dass du so
kontakte beschränkt
und viel mehr für dich dass die gc das
ist es recht schwierig manchmal es ist
echt eine schwierige frage weil ich
tatsächlich darauf getrimmt in positiv
zu denken also wenn ich mich da jetzt
irgendwie zu zwingen damit befassen
würde wie scheiße es mir geht würde ich
wahrscheinlich andere aber darauf geben
aber es ist schiebt man sehr von sich
weg ehrlich gesagt weil es geht einfach
nicht ich kann mich nicht zu hause
einsperren in einer kellerwohnung meine
dunklen keller wohnungen überlegen was
sie alles passieren könnte aber fakt ist
dass ich ein mensch bin da eigentlich
kontakte braucht er eigentlich total der
mensch ist der gerne menschen um sich
herum hat er auch konzerte geht da
irgendwie diese momente braucht um eben
gerade mit seinem anderen leben das ist
ein problem er hat mit sich bringt
umzukommen zu gehen und dann wäre halt
dann noch so was reinkommt und solche
massiven einschnitte in meinen in meinem
leben stattfinden das sich im prinzip
das was ich am liebsten mache woraus ich
meine ganze energie sauger nicht machen
kann
ich möchte darüber wacht eigentlich
gesagt was ich in meinen gesprächen
bisher und auch wenn ich recherchiert
habe immer wieder gelesen habe ist dass
menschen in dieser hauptrisikogruppe
sich vergessen fühlen kann der politik
gab es punkte in an dem du dich
vergessen gefühlt hast das auf jeden
fall das keinen fall sagen mit der
selbstorganisation zum beispiel mit
schutzausrüstung mit impfterminen ich
habe im oktober und november ich kann es
mir ganz genau sagen wann das war wo man
wusste hieß man bekommt fünf mfg zwei
masten wenn man eben nachweisen kann ich
nur risikogruppen die habe ich bekommen
ansonsten nada niente annika muss also
viel selbst organisieren damit sie
ausreichend masken hat oder schnelltests
machen kann
das betrifft viele menschen die
körperliche beeinträchtigung haben und
zu hause leben zb auch mia sie hat einen
herzfehler und dadurch eine
lungenkrankheit mit ihr spreche ich über
skype weil sie auf nummer sicher gehen
will
ja ich merke schon dass ich anderen
menschen gegenüber so ein bisschen so
eher skeptisch werde einfach weil ich
angst habe dass sie vielleicht jetzt
gerade krone haben und das kann ich mir
immer mich anstellen könnten wir leben
jetzt seit einem jahr
wie hast du sie denn psychisch erlebt
ich habe die ersten zwei monate habe ich
wirklich fast nur geweint weil ich so
angst hatte auch angst hatte alleine mit
mir zu sein und da hatte ich auch
wirklich für alle todesangst muss ich
sagen weil man da ja auch noch nicht
wusste wie das genau verläuft wie viele
menschen das anstellt wie schnell das
hier hochkommt und ja da hatte ich
wirklich todesangst und das hat sich
auch wirklich lange noch gehalten also
die ist jetzt nicht mehr so stark ich
habe eher angst dass wenn ich mich jetzt
infiziert dass meine lunge sich noch
dollar verschlechtert und ich dann auch
die transplantationsliste muss und ja
das ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt
besser dann in den gesprächen die ich
geführt haben wird klar es gibt viele
ängste es gibt sogar todesangst und
menschen mit behinderung kümmern sich um
vieles auch selbst und es gibt den
eindruck an vielen stellen vergessen
worden zu sein
was sagt denn die politik dazu es wird
es werden schon dinge oben gesetzt das
ist tatsächlich so dass wir uns mit
bestimmten aspekten auch durchsetzen
konnten
das ist keine frage aber es ist
natürlich eine ich will nicht sagen
sisyphus arbeit aber es ist eine stetige
arbeit aber auch da gilt er der satz
steter tropfen höhlt den stein
also dieser dreiklang zwischen impfen
testen und schützen das wo es besser
aufeinander abgestimmt werden da fordere
ich auch vom bundesgesundheitsminister
im gesamtkonzept wir müssen weg vom
kleinen kleinen wir müssen hin zu einem
gesamtkonzept es darf keine gewinner und
keine verlierer geben
in der pandemie also war warum ist es
denn so schwierig frage ich mich bei
menschen mit beeinträchtigungen leider
gottes nicht immer im blick von
politisch verantwortlichen sind oder
nicht hinreichend die blick von
politisch verantwortlichen sind und das
hat damit zu tun das ist meine meinung
dass eben menschen mit
beeinträchtigungen noch nicht so
sichtbar sind in der gesellschaft wie
sie sein müssten
das habe ich auch das
bundesgesundheitsministerium gefragt und
das verweist auf die ständige
impfkommission
da fällt mir ein was raul krauthausen zu
dem thema gesagt hat das wirkt die ganze
zeit ein verantwortungs verschiedene
bahnhof gemacht
und niemand ist dann auch in der lage
eine aussage zu treffen
es gibt eine million an baustellen und
zwei millionen meinungen
das ist ein einziges informationschaos
ja auch geworden ich finde es absurd wie
jetzt wie politiker innen anfang von
lockerungen zu sprechen bevor wir
überhaupt erst mal geklärt haben ob der
zeitung der liga ist
[Musik]
in diesem chaos der pandemie zeigen sich
ja so einige probleme
es wird deutlich dass die inklusion in
deutschland nicht so weit
fortgeschritten ist wie sie sollte wenn
menschen mit behinderung bei den
entscheidungen nicht immer bedacht
werden was denkt ihr darüber schreibe es
in die kommentare
in dieser pandemie gibt also einige
risikogruppen obdachlose gehören auch
dazu
dazu gibt es mehr in diesem video und
leider gilt für uns alle dass psychische
probleme in der panini zu nehmen damit
habe ich mich in diesem video
beschäftigt